i need your help so i recently signed up
with a service called patreon and it's a
really cool service that allows people
to support artists and so i created a
channel where you can support me for
making these youtube videos so these
videos are totally free for you i'm
answering questions i'm trying to help
you grow your business if you like the
videos and you feel like hey i want to
support evan and help him make more and
make them better and invest more into
these videos then you can support me and
basically it allows you to pledge
whatever you want a dollar ten dollars a
hundred dollars a month and uh it
supports the channel my my question for
you how i need help today is
with patreon it allows you to give
milestones and bonuses so if you give
one dollar or the you get this so the
first hundred people they get this prize
or if you give a hundred dollars a month
you get this and so i've been toying
with a few ideas like if you give a
hundred dollars a month i'll feature you
on the end of my videos at random um and
some other ideas but i want to get your
feedback you can check out the link in
the description below we'll make sure to
include that
um but i
i just want your feedback even if you
don't support if you don't pledge any
money that's cool not everybody's in a
position to do it and and that's fine
but i'd love your ideas what would be
cool to give away what would be a fun
milestone so if i hit a hundred people
people get this or if you donate a
certain threshold you get this kind of
prize i put a few up there that you can
check out but i just really want your
feedback as to
other ideas other creative
things that you come up with that might
be good milestones and targets to reach
so even if you can't support me
financially that's cool you can support
me with your
brain and your ideas so thanks for
checking it out and uh belief